hi everyone today I'm going to tell you
about some recent work where we
characterize chaotic dynamical systems
as an intermittently forced linear
system so we take nonlinear chaotic
dynamics and we represent these dynamics
in a linear systems framework using
Koopman operator theory and this linear
model that we get out has intermittent
forcing that essentially characterizes
these intermittent or transient events
such as lobe switching in the Lorenz
attractor bursting intermittent
phenomena like that so chaotic dynamical
systems are extremely important in many
many diverse applications and fields of
science for example the climate
turbulence the stockmarket
disease spread the motion of the planets
chaotic dynamical systems are ubiquitous
and it's one of the most well studied
and interesting problems in dynamical
systems and in mathematics in general
and so we're really excited that we have
this kind of new perspective on chaos in
terms of modern machine learning data
science and Koopman theory this is work
with my co-authors Bing Brunton Josh
Proctor Orica Kaiser and Nathan Cutts
okay so just a little bit about
dynamical systems we're going to talk
about the the classical perspective the
kind of Poincare a geometric perspective
where you have some dynamical system X
dot equals f of X and this is a system
of coupled ordinary differential
equations probably non linear and these
differential equations essentially
codify the interactions of time varying
quantities of a system right so this
could be a discretized version of a
fluid flow solver or this could be the
position and velocities of all of the
planets in the solar system lots and
lots of cool examples of dynamical
system of these coupled nonlinear
differential equations and the
traditional way that we think about
solving these is to try to understand
where particles go or where where
initial conditions where trajectories of
this dynamical system go in forward time
and
they came from in backward time so you
can integrate your dynamical system
forward in time and cook up a discrete
time kind of update so if I know my time
at time K I can tell you where the
system will be a time k plus 1 and so
for linear systems we have tons of
powerful tools to solve these right so
if this is really a linear system X dot
equals a matrix times X then there's
lots of powerful techniques for
prediction of the future state
estimation from limited sensors and
actual optimal control so you can
control the system if you can represent
it as a linear system in lots of
circumstances okay but we're used to
interacting with nonlinear systems so
the difference one of the main
differences between linear systems and
non linear systems is that in nonlinear
systems you could have multiple fixed
points so in this example you have three
fixed points a saddle in the middle and
then two centers on the outside and you
can also have periodic orbits and all
kinds of all kinds of interesting
attracting structures so as you increase
the non-linearity of your system you can
get more fixed points periodic orbits
more structure more geometric structure
organizing the trajectories as they go
through the system and time and as we
increase the non-linearity a little bit
more your system can become chaotic okay
and so I'll explain a little bit more
kind of technically what that means in a
minute but just some simple systems that
exhibit chaos my favorite is the double
pendulum this little blue double
pendulum here it's a simple system that
exhibits chaos so if you start the
system at two nearly identical initial
conditions and you let the double
pendulum go they're gonna start out
being synchronized these let's imagine
you have two double pendulum or tandem
double pendulum side-by-side you start
them at the same initial condition let
them go they're going to be synchronized
for a little bit but then very rapidly
they're going to do completely different
kind of swinging acrobatics okay and so
that idea is that the dynamics or the
trajectories are very sensitive to the
initial condition even a tiny tiny
difference in initial conditions causes
the
trajectories to diverge exponentially at
least for short times and in the
lower-right we see the Lorenz attractor
this is maybe the most famous and
classical system we use to study chaos
and so we're going to use it a lot in
this work as a motivating example where
we can really dig in and understand
what's happening ok so a little bit more
about sensitive dependence on initial
conditions this is actually an example I
used for my undergraduate math class
where we motivate vectorized integration
so here in red you see this cube of
initial conditions centered about about
a nominal initial condition that gives
rise to this this white Lorenz attractor
this butterfly attractor and if I
integrate this forward in time what you
see is that very very rapidly a few
things happen the trajectories glom onto
the the attracting surface and then they
start to smear out and get stretched by
these nonlinear dynamics so even though
all of these trajectories started out
relatively close together after a short
amount of time they get stretched and
folded by these nonlinear dynamics
almost like taffy being pulled and
folded until they eventually smear out
across the attractor ok so this is
another example of the sensitive
dependence of chaotic systems on their
initial conditions but a couple things
that are very important to note and I
think this is going to become a
recurring theme in this work is that
chaotic systems are not random if I put
a trajectory down next to a nominal
trajectory I don't get random
trajectories
I get I get structured distributions of
my initial uncertainty so here you see
this kind of red smearing of our initial
cube you get a lot of structure and a
lot of coherence and a lot of patterns
and chaotic systems so they're not at
all random but they do have this balance
of order and structure and this
unpredictability or this uncertainty
amplification in forward time very
interesting interesting field ok so we
talked about the geometric view of
dynamical systems where you have
trajectories
and you're looking at how these
trajectories are organized and mediated
by things like saddle points and
periodic orbits and attractors but a
more recent kind of theory of dynamical
systems is the Koopman operator
perspective so instead of looking at the
dynamics of the state of the system X
maybe X is all of the things about the
system I care about its position and
velocity things like that
what the Koopman operator Theory says is
that instead of propagating the state
directly we can propagate measurements
of the space of the state so this
function G is a measurement function of
our state
it could be sine of X 1 or cosine of X 2
or X 1 X 2 squared it's this infinite
dimensional hilbert space of all
possible measurement functions of our
state space and so the idea is that
there is this infinite dimensional
operator this Koopman operator K that
takes that that measurement function and
propagates it forward in time so if I
know my measurement function at time K
that's G of X of K then if I hit it with
the Koopman operator I advance that
measurement forward in time to G of my
state at time k plus 1 and so what
you're doing here is trading out these
nonlinear dynamics on a finite
dimensional state for honest-to-goodness
linear dynamics but on an infinite
dimensional hilbert space of measurement
functions so this is not a terribly new
idea this was around Koopman originated
this in 1931 but it's only been recently
in the pioneering work of message and
rally and collaborators where this
really has been been developed and I
think this is in large part because we
have now a data-driven perspective we
have tons of measurements of dynamical
systems we don't always know the
equations of motion for lots of systems
like turbulence or the stock market I
don't even know what this is but I do
have lots of measurements and so there's
this data-driven perspective that maybe
we should be propagating the
measurements of the system and Koopman
tells us that we actually have a hope of
getting a linear representation
if we choose the right measurements very
very cool and so this is a perspective
that we've taken in a recent paper that
and and you know this is synthesizing
these ideas of the right measurements
and Koopman representations if you can
find a subspace of your your measurement
space your hilbert space of all possible
measurement functions if you find a
subspace that remains invariant to the
Koopman operator so that means if I pick
any function in the subspace and I hit
it with Koopman I stay in the subspace
if you can find that kind of a
measurement subspace then your Koopman
operator restricted to that subspace
becomes a finite dimensional linear
operator on matrix and we know tons of
powerful techniques for how to handle
matrix system of equations linear
equations right we can do analytic
future prediction optimal control and
estimation all kinds of neat stuff for
linear systems so as long as you can
find a Koopman invariant subspace of
measurements you can do this amazing it
turns out that those measurement
subspaces may actually be very very hard
to find they're related to
eigenfunctions of the Koopman operator
and they carry a lot of information so
in some sense you might think they carry
more information than the geometric flow
map that solution of where trajectories
go and forward time so if you can find a
Koopman invariant measurement subspace
there's tons of powerful things you can
do but finding these subspaces might be
exceedingly difficult ok and so what
we're talking about today is really an
alternative perspective of how to get
Koopman invariant measurement subspaces
for chaotic systems ok and we call this
the Hankel alternative view of Koopman
or havoc goes next Li with chaos right
so we're looking at chaotic systems and
we apply this havoc analysis to get good
intrinsic measurement coordinates where
we can get a finite dimensional Koopman
linear approximation ok so I'm going to
outline the entire havoc analysis on
this simple Loretto stand we're going to
go through in detail all of the steps
where we can really understand
everything and then we're going to apply
this to much more complicated real world
system soon okay so the idea here this
is really based on time delay
coordinates embedding theory and also
system identification with the Henkel
operator so we start with a Lorentz
system this is the Lorenz attractor the
butterfly attractor and let's say we
only had a single measurement of the
system where you could only measure the
time history of the X variable so we can
measure this X variable in time and it
looks something like this when it's on
one attractor it's up here then it
switches down to the other low then it
switches back and so forth and the
switching is is pretty unpredictable
okay so you have one measurement
variable X but you have a time history
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to build up a set of good delay
coordinate it's time to lay coordinates
by building this Henkel matrix okay so I
take my time history X of T 1 X of T 2 X
of T 3 time 1 time 2 times 3 and I build
up this this first row of the Hankel
matrix then I shift my measurement one
measurement forward in time so I start
at time two time 3 and so on and so
forth that becomes my second row my
third row is another time shifted
version of my measurement and so on so
this Hankel matrix is built by taking
time shifted copies of the measurement
and stacking them up as rows of this
Hankel matrix kind of a cool idea not at
all new this has been around for four
decades and the idea is if I take an
singular value decomposition of this
Henkel matrix I get out these these
three matrices u Sigma and V transpose
and what we have are that the columns of
U and the columns of V are ordered
hierarchically in terms of their their
magnitude of the singular value in Sigma
and the the first column of U and V is
the most important again time series
that is most self similar to this
measurement time see
is if you've shifted it around it would
be the most correlated with this
measurement
anyway you shift it okay so that's the
first column of U and the first column
of V the second column of U and V
capture the second most variance in this
this this data in H and so on and so
forth
so what we get as this ordered
representation of these delay
coordinates in terms of the singular
value decomposition of this Hankel
matrix so that's where Hankel comes in
and again this is not new people have
used this for linear system
identification in 1985 and the eigen
system realization algorithm it has also
been used in the climate literature in
something called singular spectrum
analysis so these time series these
eigen time series are used there and
it's been recently generalized by gia
nachus and mida in the nonlinear
laplacian spectral analysis which is a
really cool kind of machine learning
take on this classic theory ok so once
you have these eigen time-delay
coordinates you can then plot your time
history in these new in this new
coordinate system so I take the columns
of V v1 v2 v3 and I plot the time
history in those columns and I get this
new embedded attractor okay and so this
is really building on talk ins embedding
theorem and and many others have worked
on on time delay embeddings for
dynamical systems and chaos in the
decades of that have followed but what
we have is that if we get the right
measurement so here X is a good
measurement
I think the Z would have been a bad
measurement if we have the right
measurement X and we build sufficiently
many delay coordinates on X then what
you have is an embedded attractor that's
diffeomorphism which is pretty amazing I
mean talk ins was looking at this in the
context of turbulence and it's a really
remarkable result that in chaotic
systems as complicated as a turbulent
fluid if you take the right point
measurement a time history of the right
point measurement you might actually be
able to reconstruct an attractor that's
divya morphic to the full high
dimensional system very very cool okay
so everything we're showing
here is so far pretty classic right
measure the system build an ankle matrix
take the singular value decomposition lo
and behold you get a similar attractor
okay so this is where the cool Koopman
in habit comes in is let's take our
Hankel matrix h and instead of writing
it at x of time one time two times three
times four let's write this in terms of
iterates of the Koopman operator okay so
X at time two is the same as Koopman of
X at time one and remember Koopman acts
on all measurements of our state and so
a measurement of X is a measurement of
our state so you can hit that with
Koopman so x at time 2 is Koopman of X
of time 1x at time T 3 is Koopmans
squared you hit it with Koopman twice so
it steps from time one to time two to
time three and so on and so forth so
every entry in my ankle matrix I can
write in terms of the Koopman operator
applied multiple times to my initial
condition X at time t1 now remember
we're trying to find a measurement space
that's invariant to the Koopman operator
so that if I'm in this measurement space
and I hit it with the Koopman operator I
stay in this measurement space and so
this is where the data driven singular
value decomposition of the Henkel
operator comes in to play here so the
columns of U are the most important
columns to expressing the columns in H
and in many many systems what you find
is that I only need maybe five or ten or
fifteen or twenty different columns of U
to express the thousands of columns of H
right I collect tons of data for H I
stack it into this big big matrix but
that matrix is often low rank and that
the low rank structure comes out of the
singular value decomposition so what we
find is that all of these columns of H
are approximately numerically at least
linearly dependent on the leading our
columns of U so our might be 15 in this
case I think in Lorentz is 15 so with 15
columns of U I can
with an almost machine precision every
possible column in H and so what that
means is that that's a measurement
subspace so those eigen time delay
coordinates in U is a measurement
subspace I measure the time history in
these u coordinates and if I hit any of
those measurements with the Koopman
operator I stay in that measurement
subspace because all of the columns are
spanned by the columns of U so this is
really a remarkable and very fortunate
fact that you get this data-driven
Koopman invariant measurement system in
terms of time delay coordinates from the
ankle ankle matrix and I'll know I'll
note that this really works the best in
the context of chaotic systems because
in the chaotic system you never really
come back to exactly the same point
you're always kind of densely exploring
your attractor so you don't get stuck in
fixed points you don't get stuck in you
know periodic orbits and so you don't
have this issue of trying to
characterize the behavior in local
neighborhoods you know with one global
linear model so this is a Koopman
invariant measurement system that's
tailor-made for the attractor where
you're collecting the data and the more
data you collect the better you know the
better your your linear dependence
assumption gets and the more
approximately you you get an equipment
invariant measurement space and I'll
note that this is this is related to
data driven ideas in a recent paper by
geo nachus and also to the nonlinear
laplacian spectral analysis so there's
you know these ideas of kind of these
closed systems in terms of time delays
is starting to come around and it's very
very exciting
okay so Koopman if we have a connection
with Koopman this motivates trying to
build a linear system on these time
delay coordinates in V 1 V 2 V 3 up to V
R ok again this is the Hankel and havoc
and this is the Koopman and havoc so
what we do now is we take the time
history of these V components so in that
this far-right matrix over here
we have these time histories of v1 v2 v3
all the way up to VR and again in the
lorentz case our is 15 and so what we're
going to do now is build a regression
model on those eigen time delay
coordinates so this is very much like
the dynamic mode decomposition or the
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics this DMD or the cindy method
where you're building these regression
models from data but the trick here is
that we're building this regression
model from eigen coordinates of the
Hankel matrix ok so we're using these
time delay coordinates to build these
regression models and we're doing it for
fully nonlinear systems not linear
systems like an e ra or d md so you
build this regression model and you find
some very interesting things ok so the
first R minus 1 delay coordinates in
this case that would be V 1 to V 15 you
get a very very good regression fit in
terms of the dependence of these R minus
1 variables on the first R minus 1 and
you have this last column for the Arth V
mode but what you find is that the fit
of the last term this R mode the
fifteenth time series eigen time series
has a terrible fit a terrible regression
model so VR dot does not equal some
linear combination of all my B's and in
fact we discovered this this whole
framework when trying out this Sindhi
algorithm on this time delay problem and
you found that even if you include
nonlinear terms this last row equation
just isn't very good it's never well
modeled with linear or even nonlinear
dynamics which is kind of bizarre maybe
we just don't have the right basis to
represent the dynamics and yet but what
this makes us think is if I omit that
bottom row and now I just consider V R
as a forcing term I actually have a
great linear regression model in my
first R minus 1 time delay coordinates
so what I have is a the
you know VDOT equals a matrix times V
plus another matrix times this last V R
okay and that's really a linear system
plus an input where that input is now
this last eigen time delay coordinate
the earth I can time delay coordinate in
in its data analysis and because of this
connection to the Koopman operator this
this havoc analysis really guarantees
that you can build this kind of model
for any chaotic system as long as you
measure the right variable so that you
get this kind of talking's embeddings so
that you get something that's really
related to the first attractor you care
about in the first place so here I'm
actually showing you results so this red
curve down here is the earth time delay
coordinates that's kind of our forcing
term because we can't really model that
so it's coming into the model as forcing
and then if you model this linear system
with that red forcing what comes out of
this linear system are the dynamics the
predicted dynamics which we're plotting
here in blue and you see that you
actually get the attractor dynamics very
very well and remarkably when the
dynamics switched from one lobe of the
attractor to the other lobe you actually
get bursting phenomenon in this
intermittent red forcing signature so
very cool right off the bat we're seeing
strong patterns and structures and the
data coming out of this and we see that
our model the blue points actually fit
the data the white curve underneath very
well and so if you run this this model
through with the right forcing you get a
reconstructed or predicted attractor
from a linear model that very nicely
matches this delay embedded non-linear
attractor and if you look at the
statistics of your intermittent
switching so that's that red curve on
the very very lower right you see so you
see the Gaussian curve is this white
dashed curve and our intermittent
forcing is very non normal so it has
these long tails corresponding to these
extreme forcing events that happen to be
quite rare so you have rare extreme
forcing events that are driving
the lobe switching of this Lorenz system
and this is very similar to ideas found
in in papers by sepsis and mida and
collaborators where they're looking at
intermittent forcing and rare extreme
events for example in climate or ocean
modeling or turbulence or things like
that so very neat connection where
you're getting this intermittent forcing
and when the intermittent forcing bursts
that corresponds to something very
nonlinear like lobe switching ok so you
can take all of those pieces of this
Havok analysis on the lorentz system so
we have the data the the real system the
time series data the embedded attractor
and then here's our linear prediction
and our forcing the reconstructed
attractor and the forcing statistics and
you can apply this to many many more
systems so we have gone into depth on
many other chaotic systems so the
Rossler attractor the Mackay glass delay
differential equation the double
pendulum and then a bunch of more
real-world examples like Earth's
magnetic field switching so this is a
very sophisticated simulation of the
pole switching the north and south pole
switching of the Earth's magnetic field
you can look at data from
electrocardiogram so these are
heartbeats or electroencephalogram from
a patient that's asleep and you can also
look at data from measles outbreaks so
this is the measles data set from New
York City I believe from 1928 to 1964 so
these are real data of real complex
systems and what I love about this havoc
analysis is that essentially if you have
this data column you can build a Hankel
matrix you can find the eigen time delay
coordinates you get an embedded
attractor and if you run this regression
model on that on these embedded
coordinates you can get a linear model
with stick with this forcing this kind
of stochastic or intermittent forcing
and it actually gives you a lot of
information about when your system is
about to switch or
first which we're about to see see
shortly so we've looked at all of these
examples all of the code is available so
you can play with any of these and
really go into depth and we're going to
again go a little bit farther into the
lorentz system because this is very
intuitive okay so what I want to show
you here is that these havoc models
these Hankel alternative view of Koopman
models actually are predictive so you
can use them to predict what's going to
happen in the future which is what a
good model should be be used for okay so
the last time delay coordinate this VR
we don't have a future prediction of VR
I told you you can't model it very well
with linear dynamics or non-linear
dynamics so we don't have a great model
for VR but if i'm collecting a streaming
data from my dynamical system i can
always compute what the current value of
VR is by taking my last little bit of
time history and dotting it with my
columns of u from the singular value
decomposition and so i can have this
kind of running window of vr up to now
and what i'm showing you here is if I
was watching this running Windows I'm
collecting more and more data I'm
watching this forcing signal when that
forcing signal gets large it tells me
that the system is about to do something
nonlinear it's about to do something
interesting like switch lobes so it's
going to switch from the top lobe to the
bottom little board that's maybe the
left in the right lobe when this forcing
signature becomes large enough okay so
what I've done here is essentially
taking the forcing signal VR and I've
also plotted VR squares you can kind of
see it a little bit more exaggerated and
just positive whenever this signal is
larger than a threshold we color the
trajectory red and so what you find is
that this red trajectory so red is
basically our our red flag that says hey
the system is about to do something like
switch and we see this signature of the
system about to switch well before it
actually switches to the other lobe so
you get almost a full revolution on the
little you're on
you know that you're about to switch on
to the other lobe so this really is
predictive you could measure your system
you could compute the up to now history
of VR and when that starts to turn red
or get large you know that you're about
to switch in the next period very cool
so you can take that color coded data
and you can now plot it on this delay
embedded attractor and what you find is
that the red regions are where this
external forcing is very large okay and
the white regions are where the forcing
is relatively small so the
interpretation here is that when the
forcing that VR is very very small then
the system is very well described by
that linear part of the dynamics that
you know V dot equals a times V so to
some extent all of this white region
here is one big Koopman linear model on
time delay coordinates and interestingly
it is kind of surrounding three
different fixed points the the saddle in
the middle and then these two kind of
centers so you know the white region is
where forcing is not active and the
system is well described by linear
dynamics and these red regions are where
that forcing becomes large and you know
that something essentially nonlinear
like a lobe switching is about to happen
and you can see that these are very
coherent they're not randomly placed you
know maybe I'm doing some loop here and
the minute my trajectory turns red I
know that after one more revolution I'm
about to switch to the other lobe okay
so very predictive and also very
structured and you can also plot the
same colors on the original Lorenz
attractor in the full system the full
XYZ system and we thought it would be
interesting to compare this to the
almost invariant sets of the perón for
BDS operator so Koopman and prone for b
Gnaeus are dual operators and so if you
look at the almost invariant sets or the
sets that kind of stay coherent under
the flow of the dynamics of the prone
fermius operator you find this very
beautiful connection so you get these
two almost invariant sets set a and
be and they're kind of dovetailed into
each other so you have the inner lobe of
the left lobe and the outer region of
the right lobe that forms invariant set
a and invariant set B is kind of the
complement it's the inner region of low
of the outer of the right lobe and the
outer region of the left lobe and so
this kind of tells you that this region
stays coherent and it's kind of
connected to this outer band here and
the same with the blue trajectories but
what's remarkable is that you have these
these two completely different analyses
per run for being is almost invariant
sets and this Hankel alternative view of
Koopman but you find that the the outer
region of these almost invariant sets
very nicely aligns with this outer
region of our Koopman Koopman analysis
okay so the inner white region again is
this kind of Koopman linearized system
and the red region on the outside are
all of the trajectory is where there's
some essential non-linearity and you
can't represent it as a as a cumin cumin
model and why might you need some
essential nonlinearities
well my Koopman operator a finite
dimensional representation of Koopman
can't possibly represent multiple fixed
points or multiple attractors or
multiple periodic orbits because any
linear system only has one fixed point
in the middle and at the origin and so
you know if you are modeling a chaotic
or a really nonlinear system using this
Koopman analysis it stands to reason
that there would be some regions of
phase space where the linear model just
isn't very good and you need something
else this intermittent forcing or
something like that so pretty cool
analysis going back to the delay
embedding I wanted to just show you kind
of the skeleton of these lobe switching
events so we start at point a this is
our just our trajectory this is a real
trajectory of the lorentz system
color-coded by that external forcing
term so we start at point a and we do
for inner revolutions on the right lobe
until point B
when this non-linear forcing becomes
large enough that our red flag goes up
so at point B we know that the system is
about to switch and it does so one
period later it switches to the to the
next attractor at Point C the forcing
becomes small and we know that we're
going to be on this attractor for a
while
so we're on this attractor for three
more revolutions and then at Point D our
red flag goes up and after one more
revolution we're going to jump back to
the right loop okay so this is very cool
there's a lot of prediction you can get
out of this analysis so you would have a
lot of heads up that you're about to
lobe switch purely data-driven okay so
again the lorentz system very well
characterized and now we can add this
rightmost column highlighting this
embedded attractor by whether or not the
non-linearity is active or not active
okay so the white regions are
essentially linear and the red regions
are essentially nonlinear there's some
forcing of the linear system that I
can't really characterize that well but
I can measure it okay so let's zoom in a
little bit more on another example the
Earth's magnetic field this is a really
cool example so what we do is
essentially run a simulation of the this
kind of averaged MHD equation with you
know turbulent fluid fluctuations that
are forcing this system and this is a
model for the dynamics inside the earth
that are giving rise to magnetic field
dynamics and all of the details are in
in this line of work down here so we
simulate the system and what we find is
that in our embedded attractor we have
to kind of clusters of points that just
stay around for a long time
corresponding to the North Pole and the
South Pole and you stay in the North
Pole orientation for a long time and
then eventually you switch the the poles
flip and you get this big jump over from
North Pole to South Pole and then it
stays on the South Pole for a while then
it jumps back to the North Pole very
cool
and this is you know been measured for
four decades you
in the actual the Earth's crust right
there the historic magnetic field does
this and this is just a model to
partially explain it so what you have
here is a time series of the the leading
eigen time delay coordinate v1 and you
see that it basically goes through these
big jump periods where it's maybe North
Pole is up for a long time then it jumps
down and it's on the bottom and it jumps
up again and again I'm plotting the
forcing term this V R and V R squared
and I'm color coding this by the
magnitude so if this thing gets above a
certain magnitude we color it red and we
say hey something nonlinear is about to
happen and when you plot those red
trajectories you find that they
correspond to the actual switching event
okay so this is very cool when the when
the magnetic field is you know not doing
anything interesting it's just
fluctuating normally that's these white
regions that's a Koopman linear dynamics
but then right when the system is about
to switch this nonlinear this forcing
term kicks on and you know that you're
about to to switch and so if we zoom
into a couple of these events you
actually see so this thing's fluctuating
fluctuating fluctuating and then it
switches on to red at this point and it
switches off from red at this point if I
just showed you this white time series
without the red coloring I am not sure
anyone would be able to tell that the
system is about to switch poles right
here I mean this is actually inside the
expected variance of this these
fluctuations but you see these
signatures in the forcing clear as day
if you measure these if you measure the
system you build these eigen time delay
coordinates and you look at the the
forcing one you get this signature clear
as day that the Earth's magnetic field
is about to switch very needs you can
apply similar analysis to this historic
measles data and so measles outbreaks is
a very well studied system and it's also
been well studied in terms of time delay
coordinates so there's this classic
paper by sugahara and May
in 1990 and so basically if you take
this this measles data and you plot it
in these eigen time delay coordinates
you find that the steady state where
there's not much measles is this kind of
white origin region here and then every
historic measles outbreak corresponds to
this bursting loop that gets big that
goes out and then comes back and the
bigger the loop the worse the measles
outbreak the more people had had measles
so you know outbreaks are kind of this
direction and study states over here and
again if we plot this in our time delay
coordinate so v1 is our first leading
eigen time delay coordinate and whenever
this gets really negative that's a bad
measles outbreak and again you can see
that when you have big measles outbreaks
you tend to have big forcing okay so the
biggest measles outbreak on this
recorded time series is the biggest
nonlinear forcing event and if you look
at the the light region up here you'll
actually see that there were a couple of
little dips that could have been false
you know little false positives that
would have said hey maybe there's a
measles outbreak but this algorithm
doesn't get tricked it waits until there
really is this big forcing that is going
to precede a real measles outbreak and
that's when it turns on and turns red
and if I zoomed in here you would see
that this forcing even the first few
moments of that forcing are much larger
than the other red events and so you
might even be able to predict that this
is going to be a particularly bad
musil's outbreak okay so very powerful
analysis you can apply this to real data
very very simply and I'll just reiterate
that all of the code is available this
is getting cropped a little but it's all
available you can download this and try
it yourself at faculty dot Washington
dot edu slash s Brunton slash havoc dot
zip okay so you could try all of these
examples okay so that's the main bulk of
the method but there's some extra things
I just can't help but tell you because
they're so cool okay so I want to dive a
little bit more into this havoc model
and the structure of this havoc model on
the
rent system and so the history of how we
discovered these these models so this is
actually the havoc model for the low
rent system this is color-coded by the
magnitude and sign of the of the entries
of the linear dynamics and the forcing
term and right off the bat you'll notice
that it has a beautiful structure it's
right off diagonal anti-symmetric it
gets stronger and stronger and stronger
beautiful structure this was originally
discovered when we applied the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
algorithm to these time delay
coordinates and we found that the most
parsimonious model even if you allow for
nonlinear terms in the dynamics is this
beautiful linear structure okay so the
very profound and this got us thinking
that there's probably a connection with
Koopman because you're getting a linear
model and then it was all all history
from there but I want to go into this a
little more so some very cool things
about this linear havoc model is that
it's sparse right most of the entries
are zero it's anti you know anti
symmetric so if it's negative down here
it's positive up here and it also
switches signs in a very interesting way
so it's blue blue blue blue that means
positive for entries negative positive
three entries negative positive two
entries negative positive one entry so
you get this cool structure of
four-three-two-one
between each of the the switching of the
negative don't really understand why
this would be true but it is and then if
you actually look at the coefficients of
these you find that they're very very
nearly integer multiples of 5 so these
might be like four point nine negative
four point nine nine point nine negative
nine point nine fifteen point one you
know very close to multiples of five
which is which is very cool okay so the
idea here is that you can take a sliding
window of your of your time series and
this sliding window is much larger you
know just so that you can actually see
it it would actually be a very very
narrow time window that you're actually
measuring you measure that time window
you can volve with your eigenmodes in
this you matrix from the singular
decomposition that gives you your
initial condition for V and it also
gives you your forcing for VR and you
can use this as you slide your window
forward to predict your system or to see
you in this forcing as large and what's
interesting here is that these eigen
time histories that are most useful to
get these V 1 through VI tend to be
polynomials for all of the examples
we've looked at almost what you find is
that the the first time delay mode is a
constant the next one is linear the next
one is a parabola then cubic quartic
quintic and so on and so forth so this
thing really is like a polynomial basis
for your time history that we're using
to get a Koopman invariant measurement
space which is really cool and I'm not
sure if you can see it here but in red
that's our 15th time delay coordinate
that we're using ticket are forcing so
you take this little teeny time window
that's sliding you convolve it with this
basis and that gives you the mixture of
v1 through VI that's active in your
system right now and if V R gets really
active that means hey we're probably
about to switch lobes okay so very
interesting that this structure this
linear structure is able to capture both
of the inner regions of the lobes of the
lorentz system and like I said you have
this very interesting structure where
these are nearly integer multiples of 5
and so this is just kind of a fun
experiment I decided to cook up a system
in MATLAB where I manually make the
system have the same rough structure but
I enforce that it is really an integer
coefficient model so the coefficients on
the lower diagonal 5 10 15 20 minus 25
30 35 40 - 45 and so on and so forth so
I take this is kind of inspired by
Lorentz but this is a neighboring system
with integer coefficients and if I take
the V 15 time series from the real
Lorentz and I run it through this
integer coefficient model these are the
dynamics I get so white are the true
Lorentz dynamics
and red are the prediction from this
integer model forced with the right
statistics with the right forcing inputs
and this is really remarkable I can't
explain this but it's very very
fascinating that there is a system a
neighboring system that almost shadows
this Lorenz system it has real integer
coefficients highly structured and it
captures the essential dynamics of
Lorentz very very well now this is just
remarkably cool I'm not sure how this
connects to Koopman or Lorentz or chaos
but I wanted to show you because it's
fish very neat ok so that is is kind of
the the overview of this Hankel
alternative view of Koopman is havoc
analysis to look at chaotic systems and
this fits into the broader framework
we're developing to go from data to
dynamics right so oftentimes we don't
have the dynamical system for systems
we're interested in but we have tons of
data and so the pipeline is you need to
measure the right things to get the
right data you need to have the right
representation so that you can represent
those measurements in a dynamical system
either linear or non-linear and then we
use relatively straightforward
regression techniques from machine
learning to actually get the models from
the data and so what I'm showing you
today in terms of this this havoc model
is that you if you measure the right the
right measurements so that you get
talking's embedding so that you can get
an embedded attractor then the right
representation for these chaotic systems
at least appears to be eigen time-delay
coordinates or these columns of the U
matrix from the SVD those give you a
Koopman and variant basis to represent
your dynamics and an honest-to-goodness
linear framework that you can get with
regression and the caveat here is that
you know this is still a very
complicated chaotic nonlinear system and
so there are regions where this forcing
still is necessarily active but
fortunately those actually correspond to
very interesting regions of phase space
where you're about to have lobe
switching or bursting in the case of
measles outbreaks
things like that so very interpretable
and very easy to go from data to these
dynamic representations that you can use
for prediction again all of the code
available on on my website and thank you
very much for your attention